PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
We're going to let capital F
of x equal the integral from 0
to x of little f of t dt.
And I want us to find the
quadratic approximation
for big F near x equals 0
in terms of the little f.
And then I want us to
answer this question.
What assumptions do we have
to make about little f?
You'll see we're making some
assumptions about little f.
I want to know what
those assumptions are.
So I'm going to give
you a little bit of time
to work on this problem.
And then I'll be back and
I will work on it with you.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you were able
to make some good headway
with this problem.
So again, what we're trying to
do, is we've defined capital F.
And we want to find the
quadratic approximation for it
near x equals 0 in
terms of little f.
Knowing that capital F of x is
equal to the integral from 0
to x of little f of t dt.
And then at the end,
we'll talk about what
are the assumptions we've made.
So to start off, what
I actually want to do
is remind us, what is the
quadratic approximation
for capital F, just
in terms of itself?
Of capital F?
So let me come over
to the right and we'll
write down what the
quadratic approximation is,
near x equals 0.
So, this gives us that F
of x is approximately F
of 0 plus F prime of 0 times
x plus F double prime at 0
over 2 times x squared.
This is just the
quadratic approximation
of capital F at x equals 0.
That's what it is.
So now all we need to do,
I've asked you to write it
in terms of little f.
So what we need to do is figure
out what each of these things
actually is.
What capital F of 0 is, what
capital F prime of 0 is,
and what capital F
double prime of 0 is,
in terms of the
function little f.
So let's see.
Well first, let's figure
out what capital F of 0 is.
Let's write down what it is.
The integral from 0
to 0 of f of t dt.
Well we know, when you
take the integral from a
to a of a function,
you should get 0.
So capital F at 0 is just 0.
So we have one piece.
Now, let's figure out
what capital F prime is.
Well, capital F
prime of x, we know
using fundamental
theorem of calculus--
let's just write it down
so we can see it easily--
we know this is
just little f of x.
So if I wanted capital F prime
at 0, I just come over here.
That's just going
to be little f at 0.
So now, if we look back up
at what we have at the top,
we filled in this part--
or we know that part,
that's 0-- we know this part.
So now all we need is capital
F double prime evaluated
at x equals 0.
And then we'll be done.
Now, how are we
going to do this?
Well we know what
capital F prime is.
So let's come in, sort of
up here, and look again.
We know what capital F prime is.
We know it's little f.
So if I want to take a second
derivative, of capital F--
let me write that down here--
that's going to be taking
a derivative of little f.
Right?
That'll be, that's
d/dx of little f of x.
So I can just write this
as little f prime of x.
So again, let me show
you where that came from.
We knew big F prime
was equal to little f.
So when I take another
derivative of this,
I have to take a
derivative of this.
So that's why capital
F double prime
is equal to little f prime.
So we're almost there.
I think I'm about to run out
of room down here, so let
me come over a
little bit further.
So now, we just need
to evaluate this at 0.
Well, that's just going to be
evaluating little f prime at 0.
So now I have all the pieces.
Let's come back in and
fill it in one more time.
So what do I get?
I get-- let me, now I
have all the pieces.
Now to answer the question.
Little f-- or sorry-- big F of
x, its quadratic approximation
is going to be big F of
0, which we said was 0.
So let's come over and look.
Here's big F of 0.
I know that's 0.
And then I'm going to add to
that big F prime at 0 times x.
That's little f of 0 times x.
Let's come back
over and do that.
So we add to that
little f at 0 times x.
And let's come back.
One more thing
we're going to need.
We need one more term.
That's big F double prime
at 0 over 2 times x squared.
That I've left big
F double prime at 0
is little f prime at 0.
So that's f prime at 0
over 2 times x squared.
So we had all the pieces.
We just had to put them in.
This does not look like an
approximately by the way.
Sorry.
There we go.
So what do we get?
This expression above
is equal to-- well why
did I write the 0 again?
Sorry I was trying to
avoid writing the 0.
It's equal to f of 0 times x
plus f prime of 0 over 2 times
x squared.
So the quadratic approximation
of capital F in terms
of little f is exactly this.
Now what assumptions are
we making about little f?
Well to apply the fundamental
theorem of calculus,
you need little f is continuous.
But we actually
need more than that.
Because what have we done?
We've actually taken a
derivative of little f.
So we need that this function,
little f, is actually
differentiable.
So that is, that actually
includes, of course,
that little f is continuous.
So we don't even have to say
continuous in the assumptions.
We just have to
say, we're assuming
little f is differentiable,
at least near 0.
So let's go back and just
remind ourselves what we did.
I'm going to go all the
way over, remind ourselves
of the problem and kind
of bring us back through.
So we started off with
this definition of big F.
And I wanted us to find a
quadratic approximation for it
near x equals 0.
And then we just mentioned,
what are the assumptions?
So I reminded you,
first, of what
is the quadratic approximation
of big F in terms of itself,
in terms of big F. And
we just write it out.
And then we had defined what
is this in terms of little f,
what is this in
terms of little f,
and what is this in
terms of little f?
And so what do we look at?
Well, we evaluate f of 0.
That's easy enough.
We found big F prime
in terms of little f.
That's fundamental
theorem of calculus.
And then we evaluate
that at x equals 0.
And then we know that
if we want to take
a second derivative
of this function,
we need to take a
derivative of the little f.
And so we get big F double prime
is actually little f prime.
So we evaluate that at 0 to
get big F double prime at 0.
And then we come in and we just
fill in everything we needed.
And so ultimately, this
is the final answer
of the quadratic approximation
of big F in terms of little
f near x equals 0.
So I think that's
where we'll stop.